but like certain things we would just
talk more about and it's like you know
stupid the way like uh college football
we were both man he got me into it your
A game is on and like you know
interception taken back for like I'm
watching the game and he's watching it
he'll go uh did you did you see that
interception I'm go yeah he goes that
was such a bad pass and I go and then he
just hang up the phone I was like he
wouldn't say anything he just hang up
all right hang up
like but these calls would happen
throughout a game and he would always
say did you see that for the game that
like he knows I'm like yeah of course
iing saw I'm watching the game dude so
but sometimes I would call him I'm like
you got to put on this other game and so
sometimes I'll be watching I'm like oh I
I gotta like I'll forget I'm like oh
he's yeah like I I'll forget in that
moment